ان هناك ضغوط غربيه على اوكرانيا لتغيير
تكتيكاتها القتاليه بعيدا عن معركه
استنزاف في المضاريه شرقا وفي الجبهه
الشرقيه اقر الجيش الاوكراني بالانسحابي
من صوليدار شرق البلاد بعد اعلان موسكو
قبل اسبوعين لاستيلاء عليها وعلنا المتحدث
العسكري في شرق اوكرانيا سيرجيو اتشريفاتي
لوكاله فرنسا انه بعد معارك صعبه امتدت
لاشهر انسحبت القوات الاوكرانيه من
المدينه الى مواقع مجهزه
وغير بعيدا عن سوليدار قالت السلطات
المواليه لروسيا في دونيت كان قوات فاجنر
الخاصه تتقدم في بلده باخموت ونقلات وكاله
تاس الروسيه عن هذه السلطات ان القتال
يجري على المشاري في الاحياء التي كانت
حتى وقت قريب تحت سيطره الجيش الاوكراني
الانسحاب الاوكرانيين من سوليدار يفتحوا
طريق القوات الروسيه بشكل كبير نحو بخموت
حيث تعد سوليدار خط الدفاع الاخير
والبوابه الشماليه الشرقيه لمدينه باخموت
احد اهم اهداف القوات الروسيه في مقاطعه
دوناتس
ولا تبعد سوليدار عم بخمس سوا 15كم فقط
وتعد السيطره على بخمه مفتاحا لسائر
مقاطعه دونيت
كما ان بين المدينتين وفق تقارير اعلاميه
شبكه انفاق بعمق يتراوح بين 80 الى 100
متر وكانت تستخدم لاغراض تعديل لكنها تتسع
لعبور الجنود والدبابات